welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Rick and Morty season four has
ended one Beth grader and countless more
key slider
despite easter-egg breakdowns and Rick's
planation for each episode there's a lot
more to talk about from these 10
episodes even harder to catch animation
details insane lingering mysteries
setting up season 5 I'm gonna break down
42 more details that you might have
missed and a little later we're gonna
dig into some of those bigger questions
from the season with their good bunny
tell me back told I'm gonna try to do
this fast because he's running out of
air season 4 episode 1 edge of tamariki
I repeat now our breakdown of that
episode covered most of these dregs
including all of Morty's and Rick's
alternate deaths reflected in the death
crystals but a new detail rick's tech to
respawn himself from a 3d printer is the
same tech that Morty uses to respawn the
simpsons that crossover couch gag when
rick responds in another dimension he
says what the hell my axe this protocol
it's a callback to Big Trouble in little
Sanchez when Rick axe operation Phoenix
in his basement Morty's death Cristal
fates include death via decapitation by
elevator doors which is a nod to nor is
death a final destination to you another
shows him eating a berry and filling up
with juice until he bursts which is
similar to the faith that Violet
Beauregarde probably went through and
really walk in the Chocolate Factory the
thing they rolled her out just in time
and Rick's future deaths include him
getting smashed by two tree trunks which
I should have known when this happened
it's a nod to with a a TST went through
and returned the Jedi also we see him
ripped in half by a giant Squatch that
has a neck collar which could be a nod
to juggernaut in Deadpool 2 who warned
inhibitor collar and ripped Deadpool in
half now Rick responds it to a dimension
that ends up being a fascist one there's
a photo signed by the president thanking
him for helping him sterilize China and
if you think about it we can assume Rick
did that with the worms from the
beginning of the season three-bin
Decatur's episode don't let any of those
things get away Morty if their DNA gets
its food chain our entire species could
be sterilized and the shrimp dimension
is of course also fascist become the
default meat to Nazi shrimp officers are
modeled on hitler's lieutenants heinrich
himmler and joseph gobbles which I gotta
say I'm actually kind of proud I didn't
know that off the top of my head when we
broke this down and a little worried
some people in the comments doing that
right away
you're just in history I get it
on to season four to the old man in the
seat on Rick's toilet planet he has a
secret tree lab which many saw as a nod
to the tree lab and gravity falls or the
hidden tree entrance in The Princess
Bride
Rick tracks stand to fly boss and
threatens his kids you might want to get
that hello bad boy so it's a cameo by
Pamela add lon who voiced Bobby hill on
king of the hill
Jerry's dream gig is the delivery guy
for mountain sweat water its logo is two
water droplets of course arranged like
testicles a joke about how jerry is kind
of blue balling and sup with his own
lame fantasies that he'll never get to
realize next season so three one crew
over the Kruegers morning at hi Scott
miles Knightley's appearance is based on
freddy mercury with his episode coming
out on the anniversary of Mercury's
death it's Kane is similar to Mercury's
microphone stand that he would carry
around his origami calling card is a nod
to a money heist on Netflix which is
further underlined when Morty pitches to
Netflix at the end of this episode in
heist montage the crew member named key
catcher just does that one job he just
catches keys in the hotel hallway and
those keys are just to blow up in a
double microwave to cause a distraction
to impersonate a guard it's all
needlessly complicated so many
unnecessary steps
initially this Warcraft wannabe has an
arm that opens up cybernetically a nod
to ghost in the shell' again she's
already a Tomb Raider okay on to season
4 episode 4 Law & Order Special Victims
Morty okay the dragon episode were a
bunch of comics got mad at me for not
pointing out what I thought was obvious
at the time but nonetheless Rick's bond
with the dragon is basically sold out
concept from dragon heart there I'm
happy that now the wizard at the end of
episode tried to protect himself with a
block of ice spell
this spell turns out is in games like
World of Warcraft and hard Stone's
wizard spell used to prevent damage
puddle areas Lee it immediately fails
here
I think that so trick uses the mind
lawyer device to make Jerry forget about
what that mystery cat did Rick carries
it in his memory later on in the vat of
acid episode in one of Morty's ultimate
Luke's he visits the mind blower chamber
we never got the story of what he was
looking at there but I've always
wondered if Morty access that cat memory
and now he lives with that truth too but
uh he's just not fazed by it because
kids seen [ __ ] season 4 episode 5 rattle
star Rick lactic ah ok the snake time
travel episode it does have this fun
visual gag early on computer you might
wanna put a rush on this morty starting
to look like a 90s japanese ghost
oh my god these snakes are a mess yeah
when the computer cuts corners the
windows on that screen each have a
corner cut off and then my favorite
detail that I overlooked from the season
when they first arrived at the advance
snake planet to intervene in their time
travel tech the white shot includes the
barely noticeable
Rick ship parked over there just around
the corner the whole time setting up the
future Rick and Morty looping back
around to this moment for the
post-credits scene awesome now the
ultimate fascist snake timeline includes
a bust of snake Lincoln with a Hitler
mustache making this snake a produc who
shows up late this season in a
hypothetical non-canon and when the time
cops intervened the prehistoric snakes
include cave markings that I initially
thought was blood spatter but this is
actually cave paintings of the snakes
painting over their own tails the way
Caedmon would paint over their hands ok
jump ahead to the second half of the
season the recent episodes season 4
episode 6 never Ricci Morty
now the train passenger assassin that we
meet early on appears to be modeled on
Wolverine
he's got similar hair sideburns heavy
jacket
just like our man Logan the car of
Rick's exes includes this ice queen that
I pointed out before but she's probably
based on Tilda Swinton's White Witch
from the Narnia movies but really
Swinton is a double reference because
this episode was based on Snow piercer
in which she played a major role and the
Amazonian X is the cartoon pepper and
this needs one Saturday morning number
two
grade her opening credits began with her
in this Amazonian forum rick is getting
around the musical theater car includes
cameos by aliens that we have seen
elsewhere in the series including the
pink pig nose race that was taken over
by the Gores o facehuggers later on and
a ploutonion from that season one
episode in the canon non-canon portal
has writing along the edge which is a
callback to Rick's line about how much
he hates portal writing and look at this
piece of [ __ ]
why is there writing on it who writes on
a portal next these important 7
primordius 1 the 9/11 jokes were pretty
in your face though many of you point it
out with this being an alien episode
Rick's less straining weapon for sure
that was a nod to the effectiveness of
Ripley's flamethrower against the
xenomorph eggs and aliens and then there
was Morty's prison song nobody knows the
trouble I've seen you know that song
Rick which at the time I attributed to
Zazu in the Lion King way he
appropriated a slave song but of course
it was also featured in space balls
Morty bursts all the glories owns
witness or Monica tune just like the
song and Mars Attacks being used to blow
up the Martians heads on TV season 4
episode 8 the amazing vat of acid
episode the animators reveal that they
designed this vat of acid chemical
plants to be completely impractical if
you look closely there's this elevated
catwalk that for no reason goes over
these open vats of acid there's nothing
to access with this elevated platform
you could just walk across this place
safely on the ground level and when Rick
reluctantly invents the time reset
remote in addition to that tvri secret
of the use - from cement II the animator
also included a clamshell device that
was based on old Polly Pocket toys and
Morty's time loop reset sequence I
pointed out how the movie theaters
marquee has ball fondlers' on there it's
a nod to that trailer showing an
interdimensional cable but this is also
a clue for us that mourning has
respawned in an alternate timeline since
that movie only exists in an alternate
dimension the Eric Clapton song was
inspired by Dan Harmon's recurring bit
in harmontown notably while Maki and
contrived as time loops and Christopher
Nolan's interstellar
what do you mean it looks like a smeared
bookcase oh it's back to the oh he's the
reason why the that's why the movie was
stupid cuz of me credits it's just the
way that she used and among the protest
signs is return the whales looks like a
nod to Star Trek for the voyage home in
which they go back in time to get
humpback whales who bring the future to
use the whale sonic frequency to stop an
alien ship maybe more to use these
whales for some similar side mission
we'll never see another scientific
Smarties face and it has the similar
crude design that Justin roiland used in
the doc and Marty channel one one short
that inspired Rick and Morty but
definitely shouldn't be watched because
it's super gross and this mob is right
to protest it ok next season 4 episode 9
children of Mort the clay children guys
are up
which first I cited as a nod to renege
two carts I think therefore I am but
it's been such a religious episode it
could also be seen it's a biblical
allusion in the Old Testament when God
presented himself to Moses saying I am
Who I am and I find the fact that there
are both biblical and humanistic
interpretations to this to be deeply
ironic the Zeus God that Rick fights has
a tattoo of the Greek letter Phi which
in mathematics is used to represent the
Fibonacci sequence
it is also known as God's fingerprint
but were you watching the season I find
it interesting that Rick's heist crew
buddy the similarly Jack Greek god
Hephaestus was also marked with a Greek
letter Omega that could imply the
existence of 24 Greek gods in this
universe one for each letter
Jerry's tribe of unproductive clay
people later marked themselves with body
paint as does Jerry that matches his
dumb shirt pattern and lastly we've
arrived at season 4 episode 10 starboard
Rick turn to the Jerry I pointed out a
lot of the fun details with space Beth
and her crew but in addition to female
counterparts to Squatch in chrome
populous Michael there is a droid based
on l3 37 the droid voiced by Phoebe
Waller bridge and soloist Star Wars
story space Beth has a blue streak in
her hair the same shade as Rick's hair
showing this version of the best closer
evolution to her father but also million
odd to the alternate evil Britta and
community who had a blue streak in her
hair if she thought that would be cool
space bed mocks normal Beth's domestic
life you fetch your shitty father's
lemonade back and seize them once closer
counters of the Rick kind Beth does
serve lemonade to all the Rick agents
when they take over her house on dr.
Wong's desk is a brain statue that many
claim could be a nod to blind Ivan from
gravity falls but I'm thinking it's just
the old-school phrenology statue that
commonly sits on the desks of
psychologists and blind Ivan's character
design was just based on this however
there is a super subtle cameo by cipher
bill from gravity falls and the post
credits scene and the alley on the right
side he sees all and he also is missable
number 42 Douglas Adams fans that was
not an accident now before you jump in
the comments to call me an idiot for
missing read me sake sir Dan Harmon
story circle or all the icky references
I was just covering my bases for the
stuff I missed in my first breakdowns
and were explained episodes so there's a
good chance I already
your precious comment in one of those
videos so go watch them you know just
don't comment don't care let's move on
to Tommy to discuss the big lingering
mysteries from the season he's got a
couple breaths of air left oh we can
make him wait a little bit longer now
that Rick and Morty is back on hiatus I
get my Sunday nights back which means
more time for snoozing thanks to helix
sleep for helping me out in sponsoring
this episode
helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses made right here in America
and shipped straight to your door with
free no contact delivery free returns
and a 100 night sleep trial to juice
mattress helix made a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you if you like
a mattress that's really soft or firm
you sleep on your side or on your back
or on your stomach or if you sleep just
really hot with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste I took the quiz and I was matched
with the helix luxe mattress because I
wanted something that felt perfectly
medium and I tend to sleep on my back
you know just to make the spiders crawl
in my mouth and not the other end but
these sleep spiders don't bother me
anymore I am just sleep it's so much
better and waking up feeling more
refreshed and ready to have my heart
broken by the latest comments on our
videos
I love Felix but you need to take my
word for it Felix was awarded the
number-one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by GQ Wired magazine and Apartment
Therapy so just go to helix sleep comm
/r explained take their two-minute
sleeve quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress they'll give you the
best sleep of your life they got a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will love it Felix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep comm /r
explained that's helix HCl IX
sleep comm /r explained for up to $200
off and we are back here to review the
biggest questions we still have from
season four of Rick and Morty superfan
and human easter-egg we will crack one
day Tommy Beck told
welcome back buddy we missed you last
week I'm so glad to be back and you will
try to crack this egg but much like
Humpty Dumpty I have a dedicated group
of king's horses and king's men that
reassemble me every time I breathe you
should start paying them Tommy because
they do the Lord's work
that's true alright let's talk about
some of the big mysteries that the
season left us with that hopefully will
get addressed in season 5 when it comes
back whenever okay the first one let's
talk about the finale cuz you weren't
here last week and and there was some
questions I actually really need your
thoughts on this whole idea of space
Beth is back on the show what does this
mean for the series are we gonna have -
Beth's in every episode now that like we
could explore conflicts with or like
favoritism with like what does this mean
for the series that there are - I I
really hope so because I like their
dynamic together and it presents a I
mean a pretty formidable foil for Rick
but yes they have the kind of like one
kryptonite to him which is he is a bad
father he can't really deny the fact
that he's been a bad father now you
could argue he might deep down really
not care about that
but it does appear that it that like his
family's disapproval does bother him to
a certain degree his actual effect the
people he considers truly his family I
don't think he cares if Jerry
disapproves of him but like right if
summer or bath or Morty really really
disapprove or really really are bad or
disappointed in him that does seem to
get through his armor a little bit I
really hope we see both Beth's in as
many episodes as possible I just think
they're interesting I think it's really
interesting the way that was done
absolutely and the the way that they
went from conflict to pretty quickly
working together having that Parent Trap
reference of like let's go pear type
thing the Lindsay Lohan version yeah
they they really do balance each other
out really well and you know Cassie
Steele last week was like she saw like
this weird kind of romantic chemistry
between them and I agree really watching
the episode there's something weird
there that whether or not is romantic
definitely could pose a threat to ring
and just that battle between space Beth
and Rick with the Pokemon balls and
everything like they the two of them
represent Rick's worst and strongest and
most aggressive qualities but with two
people
they'll be interesting to see if that
ends up being like a conflict two-on-one
conflict totally totally
I I would be very interested to see that
and I don't know maybe I was reading too
much into it when they said I want to do
a Parent Trap thing later the you know
the plot of the parent trapper the twins
work together to get their parents back
to you yes very good point yeah I mean
we we talked to an earlier episode this
season Tommy about this whole mystery of
Rick's wife Diane Sanchez who we presume
is dead there's all these conspiracy
theories around her does this get us
closer maybe to seeing Diane Sanchez an
understanding what exactly happened with
her I think it's got you I mean I just
don't think that they make mist like
they don't waste threads like that you
know to even reference it or to allude
to Rick's romantic life is to you know
kind of open up the possibility and we
know Rick is shitty enough to have just
sent her somewhere knowing he could
bring her back like you know like this
could be this could cut I mean this
could be a de-escalation of the point
where like they got in a petty argument
and he sent her away because he was
angry and then forgot or like you know
what I mean something like that or or
she left him maybe maybe she rejected
him and maybe that's why he treats her
as though she's dead because she is dead
to him I don't know but I think that
that is a great mystery of the show that
it's gonna be a lot of fun to watch them
unpack and I and I really believe that
they will tackle that I don't know how
soon but I hope it's sooner than later
yeah I mean here's the deal I went
through a period I don't know if you
felt this way this season Tommy but like
I really thought that the writers were
clearly saying you know what there is no
such thing as canon on the show anymore
each episodes of the in its own universe
there'll be some continuity but I'll
take the continuity too seriously but
then by the end of this season
especially with the idea of clone Beth
coming back with a Phoenix person and
tani coming back the Federation coming
back in that yeah that was such a
deliberate move of continuity like these
writers when it suits them they
absolutely will bring back all these
plot threads of evil Morty and mr. poopy
butthole and yeah maybe all these
mysteries I think we can
we can speculate it's okay to make
predictions I think now and it's like
you know it's such a smart show that's
obvious that's kind of a dumb statement
about a smart show but like it's it's
really like all these little breadcrumbs
in like me and and you know like the the
like cannon doesn't matter the stories
don't like you know the like the the the
the plot lines don't matter it's just
the like that what's happening right now
in the show is what's important leading
up to you know just kidding it does
matter this is the story there's another
kind of brilliant storytelling thing
that they did basically like oh is this
gonna be the type of thing like an
upturn into a Simpsons cartoon likes
thing where it's like you know it's
basically a day in Springfield that has
no right in the connection there might
be some loose character plot points that
are the same like you know Maude
Flanders is dead but that's you know
other than that it's a brand new
encounter between Homer and Ed with no
past ramifications other than just what
the two characters feel about each other
so you know not to sacrilegious lis
bring up another cartoon but it was
interesting that they then went away
from that went back to now these are
direct timelines story points so I know
I just think I just you know not to gush
about it but it's just such a smart show
and so fun to watch oh gosh show you
what Tommy this is your turn to Gus I've
kept you in this chamber waiting for the
first half of the episode to finish so
this is your your time to gush gush away
that I'm gushing well in speaking of
sacrilege I'm pulling a segue line from
like a paragraph ago the whole children
of more episode 9 where Rick killed what
we thought was God for a second but now
it's just a Zeus it's one of many God
figures Titans of this universe and Rick
did say there is a real God exists I'm
carried like who do we think the real
God could be like who is the real God
will we see the ultimate god of the Rick
and Morty universe the one above all and
what form do we think that'll take do do
I don't know is it someone we've already
met is like you know is it is it not not
to tie into a future thing we're gonna
talk about but like is that the thing
that the cat did
oh that's a cool theory if that all the
horrific natural disasters acts of God
as insurance agents would call it are
all the cats doing oh that would be
amazing
and knowing that it was preventable and
like all of them are knowing that they
could have prevented it and instead
didn't you know oh I love that idea and
it's Matthew Broderick yeah yeah I would
uh men running through the characters
who exist like if meeseeks could be a
form of God you know like Jeannie's in a
way are godly and if they you know one
God in many forms the God like God can
take several infinite duplicates yes oh
sure me the meeseeks box could it's kind
of a god box or or maybe like mr. poopy
butthole hey maybe Diane Sanchez this
guy Rick's ex-wife is the god of this
universe and that's where she is
yes I like it I like it maybe mr.
goldenfold oh yeah let's get Brandon
Johnson to do more episodes
oh let's let's dig a bit more into that
cat though because that is a mystery
that several we made an episode of
Rick's planed about that I think film
theorists lots of people are digging in
that my big take was that it had to do
with like sex crimes or pedophilia right
cuz that whole episode was so gross you
know the horny Dragons and yeah the fact
that like he wanted to go to Florida
there's just you know being for Florida
there's a lot of those types there it's
but what else could the cat have done
why was it so disgusting to Jerry and
Rick I know yeah and the thing is it was
a consensus disgust from Jerry and Ray
who don't see eye to eye i'm literally
anything so you know how unifying lee
horrific it must be because the two kind
of antithesis characters were both on
board with it being awful so I think
yeah crimes against a child or or
something like that or I'm trying to
think of like what would be something
they bow
had in common that would be you know
that devastating because Rick is such a
kind of nihilistic character that like
you know some sort of atrocity might not
really faze him you know what I mean
like a like a grand atrocity might not
be right masterminding 9/11 not to be
you know glib about that but like I saw
like a 9/11 like terror attack probably
wouldn't force Rick to have that
visceral of a reaction and you know
that's right so right
so I don't know I think the thing is
it's above my it's above my intellect I
just don't I think unless it's what you
said you know I think unless it was kind
of a sexual horrific cat like you know
ultimate societal taboo or ultimate
societal like you know thing that is
universally looked as grotesque and
horrific I don't know I don't know yeah
it's uh it kind of reminded me of that
trigger moment in event horizon which
our discord people know has haunted me
since I was ten years old but that idea
of like you know he gets his vision of
all of his crewmates being tortured in
hell that's something that it's just so
cosmically impossible to fathom on a on
a Lovecraftian scale you know like I
wonder rick was so worried about his
parents he said i pictures of my parents
they're like i wonder if it because his
parents might be closer to death like
he's worried maybe this cat is like a
version of satan which i know we saw the
devil in season one like i wonder if
like this cat is a type of demon that
tortures like people who go into the
afterlife and that's why he was worried
it's like oh he identified my parents
it's kind of like you know you
introduced the hooded figure of death
the specter of death it's like oh this
guy's one you know heartburn away from
from croaking and being your slave now
maybe that was what was was like a
religious kind of fear yeah sure
that would make sense yeah yeah I'm
gonna be thinking about this endlessly
just because they gave us just enough to
make us wonder but it doesn't seem like
the over answer I hope they do I hope
that guy comes back I hope they do too
but that feels like something that they
would relish in not ever answer yeah
all right tell me I want to close out
here with let's just do our our
subjective rankings from episodes one
through ten of this season and kind of
rank them down from our least favorite
to our most favorite okay so I'll start
with I'll start with my ranking and you
can jump in there and disagree and then
kind of tell me your ranking we'll see
how they disagree and we'll fight for me
number ten I think the the dragon
episode claw and hoarder was probably
the least structured and just a little
too like I don't know a little too
immature I think as some of the jokes
the writers are very mature complicated
people but this is one where they
probably were just like letting their
riffing run a bit too far I agree I
think I think you know I was gonna say
earlier they got one for me upon a
second and third watch is what got
increasingly less funny and more kind of
like huh okay like you know it it felt
to me like when you're joking with your
friends or like you know one of those
text threads that will get you all
canceled forever but like they're you're
on with like really close friends and
you're like just trying to out like joke
each other it but it's but it's not an
actual good humor it's just making
things that will make people go oh god
like you know you're trying to out
horrify yeah they're like I felt like
the jokes were yes okay like yeah I get
it I kind of get why that's funny but I
don't know it's just a little gross and
you know kind of sad that I described
that episode of soggy soggy is a good
word for it I think the writers gambled
on the idea of Game of Thrones being
still really popular and flying high it
didn't count on the fact that the final
season of Game of Thrones would so piss
off viewers that we were just kind of
done like I think they're hoping that
that would trigger us to be like oh you
know what dragon stuff is kind of stupid
but like we had already come to that
conclusion months early yes you know
sure great point I think my number 9
episode of the season would be the
primordius episode the facehugger
episode 7 only because i did like this
idea of starting in the middle of things
that not even realizing that were in the
middle of an episode and going back to
the beginning i and i thought the 9/11
joke was super funny and then they
bombed Pearl
Harbor instead it's just Rick and Morty
has kind of asked that question of
itself of like what if we become or we
the bad guys in in other more
interesting ways like the purge planet
yeah episode I that was an interesting
one so it just didn't really feel like
it broke any new ground for me yeah I
agree
I agree yeah so next up number eight I
would rank the old man of the seat
episode two I love the idea of a shy
pooper um and I think we can relate with
that but it felt like it was just a bit
too small of an idea that didn't really
manifest into something more and I think
this show has pulled that card out
enough times I've in an episode of Rick
being depressed and I felt like of the
episodes that ended with Rick being
depressed this one didn't earn it as
much as the rest of them did I think I'm
just a softie and the yeah the
friendship between Rick and I can't
remember either way the the the
friendship between them kind of got me
and the fact that Rick really did
actually like him and I think you know
showed some vulnerability I but I also
like bad rom-coms and like you know I
cry over iphone commercials so I can't
be trusted
yeah I certainly can't be trusted so I
make it a little higher but only for
those reasons um what I did like about
this episode though that I ranked higher
was the whole love finders a pile of had
how it complete however very quickly
reset people to a new match and I
thought that whole side of the episode
was amazing episode 7 I rank the the
story train episode the mid-season
premiere episode 6 a lot of people were
mad by the kin and non-kin and stuff but
I thought it was a really cool concept
using this kind of snowpiercer infinity
train thing to tell like to break down
how story structures work and to use an
anthology story I thought it was really
clever thing especially now that the
that didn't actually destroy these
hypothetical subplots um we wanted to
see come back there was just one episode
addressing it I thought was really great
I really really really enjoyed that
episode and then next up number 6 what I
thought episode 3 the crew heist one
crew over the crew cruise Morty was
super fun like old man in the seat it
was kind of like a petty gripe of Dan
Harmon of the other writers of like
these heist films we know from
harmontown how Dan Harmon Hey
be now you see me series and these other
movies because these right they are
completely contrived but I love how the
whole episode became this complicated
rug pulling out underneath you know this
is the twist no this is a twist I
thought that was a really fun the way it
kept the birdie I agree I loved it
and again to me this is your Gustin time
you don't have to agree you can you can
fight me like anyone likes you I didn't
call me an idiot you know I'm thinking
back and I'm like why I really liked
time heist episode I really love the
story train episode I'm like wow are
they really these low-ranked but this
was such a loaded season this was a
really really yeah really good season
that I don't know I guess like thinking
of the episodes that we still have that
I'm like yeah I can't rank any of them
lower than this for the for Count
Chocula alone I might you know it's like
these are just little things that make
me you know wake up in the morning yeah
I can't I can't put my individual
selfishness ahead of the greater good Oh
for the Rick and Morty fans out there by
by moving my rankings I stand by you
thank you buddy
yeah I totally agree even the Dragon
episode as much as I you know didn't
like it as much as the other episodes
this season the bits in it we're really
solid I think you know the jokes on this
show even a bad episode are still really
good it's still really well-written and
they put effort into it my my episode 5
is my ranking number 5 the snake time
travel episode it broke the time travel
rule sort of for snakes yeah I guess but
they they were so committed and
dedicated to telling as good of a time
travel story as they could and the
mission by the end of the episode was
erasing the existence of time travel
from this universe I thought was really
really clever in the way that they used
snakes as a snake eating its own tail
it's kind of like a double metaphor
there I that was really impressive
yeah i again i think for me i
emotionally would rank this lower than
the time heist i was at hand the story
train i was a just based on enjoyment
but i can't i can't have what you're
saying
in terms of yeah actual physical episode
so I will yeah I could see a lot of
people were kind of mixed on the snake
one I'm I'm just glad that they did do a
time travel one but they like they knew
we're doing you know I will simply throw
a Susan Collins I'm concerned that's
what I was very concerned it's
concerning to me but I will not do
anything about it
okay ranking number four on my ranking
the season finale the the Beth clone
episode the star Mort Rick turn of the
Jerry I thought the fact that clone Beth
came back it was such a fun storyline
the fact that they were able to bring
back in Tammy and birdperson slash
Phoenix person in the way that didn't
feel fans perfectly but felt kind of
deserved and in lovely I I thought it
was such a fun way to in the season oh
and I also say that the whole way it
ended of just not giving us an answer on
whether or not Beth is a clone or which
Beth is a real clone or the real one I
thought was very true to the series and
and very mature of the episode in that
way so and I felt like I mean maybe this
is just me the reveal that he has
Phoenix person in his garage was very
Shawn TEI desk where he's yeah yeah
we're playing video games with Nick
Frost character at the end and he's
still trying to bite him but but still
playing yeah III very much I enjoyed
that Phoenix person is now I'm not BP
anymore I'm peep yeah yeah but I enjoyed
that alright getting to our top three
here I think my number three episode was
the two planet episode the children of
Mort because I felt that this did some
really profound science versus
creationism Bates on multiple levels by
having Rick fight a god and having their
champions their surrogates on the
planet's surface
fighting out and scene it was one of
those like things my favorite Jerry
storylines of the and I think you can
judge an episode of Rick and Morty by
how good the Jerry storyline is yes that
that was gonna be my interjection was
Jerry was on fire this episode and this
was a great great great all-time great
Jerry
mashing all-time great Jerry I hate yes
viewing from from the man himself yeah
this was I can't argue great Jerry
episode my number two episode was the
season premiere the Rick died Rick peed
the death crystals of poor mojo on
crystals I thought that season premiere
was one of the series best the fact that
it likes showed all the different Morty
and Rick deaths in the future the whole
Rick respawning and different timelines
of they're all fascist because that's a
default now I thought there was it's a
true episode of Rick and Morty exploring
it in every possible way you could
explore it I'm amazed that they had all
of this in one I loved it I completely
agree the like just thinking about it
makes me laugh II like the whole the
whole revelation that Morty's
relationship with the girl from his
school is still just her kind of yeah
really not knowing really where Kerry is
just her base level human decency and
like just the fact that's all this is
such a depressing but hilarious like I
don't know tangent to go on so yeah I
agree and then yeah I think I know what
episode is left and I'm certainly in
consensus with you and the number one
episode yeah the vat of acid number one
and I think we gotta give this episode
even more love because the fact that it
was truly collaborative and probably the
most limited amount of time that the
writers and animators had to work on it
go watch all the behind the scenes on
this episode because the writers will
tell you how they really they wrote it
in like a day so for the level of
sophistication of the jokes being at
least on par or better that whole like
animated montage of Morty's life with
this girl like that was just visual
storytelling and that's what you know
animation is great writing of course but
like animation is visual storytelling
and that union between the writers and
the animators is what makes Rick and
Morty so amazing and the fact that they
could just hand it over to the animators
to just tell this heartbreaking but
hilarious story I I thought it started
out as such a simple concept episode
that felt like we were just gonna sit in
a fake barrel of
for 22 minutes and but the fact that it
went to these emotional depths but
grounded back in this concept of this
prestiging you know another multiverse
concept told in a way we hadn't seen
before
that was another classic episode of Rick
and Morty that if if people hadn't seen
the series before that of acid would be
yeah the ones I started I think you know
as more time goes by I think it's my
favorite episode of the entire show it's
so good the tail kind of the cop going
on Johnny Carson I'm acid funny in such
a ridiculous like what an irrelevant
joke to me but just so so funny so yeah
IIIi think my only gripes with your list
would simply be I might put the time
heist and story train episodes ahead of
the time travel snake episode and
another and and the old man in the seat
episode I might emotionally rank higher
but I logic would probably be able to
calm me down and let it remain where it
is so other than that I think the list
is spectacular Erica give you yeah and
you're not wrong for for defending those
episodes more because as we this is why
I'm increasing about rankings cuz like
people are always like bring the MCU
movies which we will but like I had to
in our discord rank Rick and Morty
amongst the other animated series of
like all-time best animated series and I
knew as soon as I posted my ranking I'm
like Simpsons is gonna be number one for
me because I grew up with it and like I
cannot explain to someone who's 10 years
younger than me how amazing The Simpsons
is because to them that you tell them to
watch one of the best episodes you know
ports else's soul or who shot mr. burns
they just can't understand how funny
that is because it by the standards of
Family Guy
South Park Rick and Morty Archer it's
just too slow for them and they're but
like and I can't it rankings are
subjective and they'll get real mad at
you if you rank something higher than
absolute that they feel like it's it
sets up conflict and we're peaceful man
yes yes we are peaceful
and I also rank a South Park higher than
Ricker I love Rick and Morty it's just
only been in four seasons those Simpsons
a South Park had like at least ten
amazing season more than ten episodes
I'm sorry I don't you know what spoil us
spoil us it's like when people compare
John Oliver to some of these other talk
shows it's like yeah if you're spending
all this time putting all the same
writing staff is put in all their effort
into this much content yeah that
contents gonna be way better but like if
you're trying to make 22 episodes or
daily episodes as they are for talk
shows yeah kinda this is gonna be
there's gonna be more filler absolutely
just how it works
anyway but kudos to everyone on the set
good morning thank you for giving us a
great season and take your time with
season five you know life don't rush it
well that's a wrap on this season ever
explained big things of Tommy back told
you've been a great wingman throughout
all ten of these episodes it's been a
blast talking about the show with you
man Thank You Erica thanks for including
me I love getting a chance to do these
shows with you it's a real highlight of
my week I mean that sincerely so thank
you for including me again I hope we get
to do it for next season
yeah man and you know between now and
then we'll have like plenty of other
stuff on this channel for those of you
who love seeing Tommy we all love having
Tommy on new rock star stuff so check
out rogue theory a big question Tommy
will often show up there and hopefully
new formats will be able to roll out
soon where where we can get Tommy in
there as well
we love this guy nice - thank you Eric
and thanks to all the guests who joined
us this season - Rick and Morty Brandon
Johnson Cassie Steele a coke alum Tara
Strong Nolan North Ryan Ridley avid
Ghaith Jessica Chobot Sam batcher
any others I might be forgetting you're
all so great you can also get early
audio versions of the show by
subscribing to Rick's blade wherever you
get your podcasts follow me on social
media follow new rock stars follow Tommy
subscribe to this channel for more Rick
and Morty breakdowns we will close out
this week with a montage of each of our
favorite lines back-to-back for your
enjoyment but first something silly what
do you mean but first I already said up
next you always do those always do [ __ ]
don't gasoline - lighting doesn't exist
you made it up because you're crazy what
the hell are you doing
parenting
it's not how I did it yeah where's your
daughter hey you're right she join Isis
Rick Sanchez everyone smartest man in
the universe and a savage critic of the
high sting arts you know who's into
dragons Morty
nerds that refuse to admit their
Christian want my dragon Real Talk buddy
where yeah go to hell Rick can you
recognize the sound of a man's pants
filling up with rain I hope to one day I
guess I'll return in return are you
insane
did you hear nothing I said buy another
one Morty consume Morty
nobody's out there shopping with this
virus where's your I'm acid-proof all of
you all of you I'm gonna be rich here's
my ass take a good look father or not he
was a lying piece of [ __ ] I don't care
who else stuffed your crust but I'm the
guy that showed up made me go to a
wedding and you killed my best friend I
should have said that one first
[Music]